the planet earth is part of the
planetary system with the sun in its
center
as we all know it is the star we orbit a
relatively small number of stars located
near it by space standards
and their planets are not likely to be
as favorable for sustaining life as we
know it
as our earth so far there seems to be
not a hint or indeed the slightest
chance of there being intelligent life
elsewhere in space
however there are a number of stellar
systems in space whose properties are
identical to those of the solar system
and it's been a while since those
discovered counted by the dozen
they actually account for several
billion in the entire milky way
for the past several decades astronomers
all over the globe
have been trying to discover at least
one that would reveal signs of life
and it was only in the 21st century that
science has started to get somewhere in
its attempts to find evidence of there
being life out there
it was made possible largely thanks to
the discovery of the trappist-1 system
this object is a single star with a
planetary system and there are at least
three celestial bodies within the
habitable zone
now let's look at it in more detail the
distance between trappist-1 and our sun
is and a half light years the object was
discovered in the period from 2016 to
2017.
this single star is a red dwarf of
spectral type
m8v as for its dimensions
it is only 12.1 percent of our sun's
radius
just to compare it isn't in fact much
larger than jupiter
the mass of trappist-1 is 27 000 times
that of our earth
but at the same time is 0.08 the mass of
our sun
with the average temperature reaching
2500 kelvins
its luminosity is 1900 times weaker
in comparison with that of the main star
of our system
the orbital period of trappist-1 is 3.3
days
as for its age it is seven and a half
billion years
which makes it almost three billion
years older than the sun
the distance between this star and us is
diminishing
as it is slowly but surely drifting
towards our system
this object aroused interest largely
following the discovery of its planetary
system back in 2016
whose three components were spotted by
transit method with the help of an
automated 0.6 meter telescope in the
european southern observatory or the eso
in chile the planets were initially
dubbed trappist-1b trappist-1c
and trappist-1d however further
investigations revealed that the
presumed location of trappist-1d
was described incorrectly following that
four more
earth-like objects were discovered by
astronomers with the help of the spitzer
space telescope
these were dubbed trappist a f g
and h thus the total number of planets
in the system reached seven
and on the 13th of april 2016 the
parameters of these celestial objects
were defined in more detail all the
seven exoplanets
are identical to our earth in terms of
their dimensions
with their radii ranging from 0.71
to 1.13 that of our planet planets b
and c orbit their parent star in the
periods of 1.51
and 2.42 days respectively
initially according to astrophysicists
both of these planets were comparable to
venus
in all but exceptionally high
temperatures
however after their mass and density had
been measured
it was trappist-1 that could be called
venus's analog
trappist-1b the second closest planet to
its star
is likely to contain a large amount of
water and other volatile elements
the new data enabled scientists to find
out more about the other discovered
planets too
it takes trappist-1d 4.05 days to orbit
its star
its radius is 0.77 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1e is 6.1
days
its radius is 0.92 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 f may
last
up to 9.2 earth days its radius is 1.04
that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 g is
12.3 days
and its radius is 1.13 that of the earth
last but not least trappist-1 h is the
seventh object
and is the furthest from its star with a
rotation period of 18 days
and a radius of 0.7 that of our planet
it should be mentioned that the initial
estimates of the object's masses were
likely to be rather conservative
due to the analysis of the density of
the first six planets
it was later ascertained that they
contain a big amount of water and other
volatile elements
which makes them considerably lighter
than thought previously
as for the furthest of them e f g and h
for all we know they may consist
entirely of water
only trappist-1c boasts a mass bigger
than initially estimated which may be
indicative of over 50 percent of iron in
its composition
of the seven planets known to be located
in the trappist-1 system
three of them find themselves within the
habitable zone
namely d e and f speaking about the rest
of them
following the estimates of its density
planet b is thought to contain either a
small nucleus
or else a considerable amount of
volatile elements
due to high temperatures of 127 and 69
degrees celsius above zero
on the surfaces of planets b and c
respectively
water is not likely to remain in its
liquid state there
and is bound to float about as vapor as
for planets g
and h they're too remote from their
central star to be potentially habitable
however according to models suggested at
cornell university
the habitable zone of trappist-1 may
well be wider
and allowing for volcanic hydrogen
potentially acting as a greenhouse gas
there may be four planets within the
habitable zone
rather than three the density of
trappist-1 f
is rather low too and so it may well
turn out to be an
all-ocean planet
here are the temperatures for all the
planets in the system the steady-state
temperatures are given without including
incident light dispersion
and greenhouse effects just to compare
the steady-state temperature on our
planet in the same conditions
would measure four degrees above zero
and on mars
47 degrees below zero
in november 2017 it was posited that the
activity of the star didn't allow its
planets to form and maintain their own
atmosphere
it is accounted for by the fact that
trappist-1 goes through periods of
active flares
which may negatively affect the nearby
celestial bodies
and thus render them uninhabitable for
living organisms as we know them
interestingly the planets are located
much closer to each other in comparison
to our systems planets
the planet mercury which is the closest
one to the sun
is located 0.39 astronomical units from
it
while the distance between trappist 1b
and its parent star
is just 0.01 astronomical units
as trappist-1 is a rather dim star it is
no easy matter to explore it
red dwarves like that are quite
widespread across the universe
accounting for most of the galaxy's
stellar matter
plasma ejections on these stars are a
rare occasion
although astronomers believe that there
may be giant cold areas and compact hot
areas with temperatures upwards of four
thousand
kelvins on the surface of trappist-1
if this conjecture proves to be true
scientists will proceed to confirm that
the system's planets are constantly
bombarded by powerful
ultraviolet and x-ray radiation which is
able to destroy their atmospheres
and render their surface completely
sterile
the reason for that lies in the fact
that none of the microorganisms known on
the earth are able to withstand
intensive radiation
emanating from flares of this kind
including the most radiation resistant
bacteria dana caucus radiodurans
nevertheless in december 2017
atmosphere was proven to persist even in
periods of high activity of stars
which implies that planets g and h may
potentially have their own atmospheres
at the moment astrophysicists idea is to
use more up-to-date telescopes for
studying the matter
for example the james webb space
telescope whose launch is planned for
march 2021
today the trappist system presents a
great interest for the global scientific
community
and even though it is highly unlikely
that any advanced civilization will be
discovered on its planets
we cannot ignore the fact that life
forms in the universe may be extremely
diverse
and may differ from our perceptions of
life as we know it
which implies that not all intelligent
organisms are supposed to follow the
scenario of our planet
if science manages to find out more
details about this system in the nearest
decades
many conjectures and doubts we have
today about trappist-1
will most likely be cleared
every new object of the kind discovered
by scientists heralds yet another leap
forward by our civilization
and it's a pleasure for me to be telling
you about it thanks to your support when
you like our videos and leave your
comments
our project keeps growing and i'm really
grateful that you helped the cosmo
channel to improve
i hope that we will soon be able to have
the pleasure of sharing some more
information about this fascinating
stellar system
because the process of its exploration
is only just
starting let's keep in touch
[Music]
you